(audience applauding)
- Thank you, welcome,
welcome, everyone, welcome.
Welcome, transfer students,
visiting international students,
Eli Whitney students, and
welcome, first year students.
(audience applauding)
So happy to see you all after
a fantastic move in weekend,
you all brought the best
weather in many years,
so I think you're off to a
great start to your four years.
Did you enjoy Bulldog Bash?
(audience cheering)
We should do it again next year.
Okay, good, okay, thanks.
Yeah, and really hope
you're all getting settled
and excited for the year ahead.
Classes start tomorrow morning.
And one thing you're gonna find out about
classes around here is
that you have some time
to pick what you're gonna take,
we have this shopping period.
And to try out the courses
you wanna take first.
And of course, that's
what I hope you'll do.
It's a really exciting
time, a little hectic.
But a lot of it's about
juggling a lot of the options
and choices, great choices that you have,
as you make up your minds.
But before any of that
happens, today, this afternoon,
we are gonna have this opportunity
to think in the broadest sense
about the intellectual
community that you're joining.
And to start thinking about your own
intellectual life here at Yale.
Some of you may have
planned out every semester
for your entire four years ahead,
down to every class you will take.
While some of you are just the opposite,
not knowing even where to start.
And of course, that's all good.
And many of you are probably
somewhere in between
with a general idea of what
your next move will be,
but with an openness to new ideas.
So whatever you have in mind,
I hope this afternoon
that you will get a sense
of the world of ideas
that are awaiting you.
And there's also some
practical business today
that we'll attend to later on,
which is learning how to
sing "Bright College Years."
And so with help from the Glee Club
which is with us here today,
you'll get a chance to practice,
and then by the time you leave this place,
you'll be able to take your
place besides Yale students
and alumni who know this
song inside and out.
And you have the lyrics with
you as part of your program,
and we'll come back to
this after our speech.
So it's now my pleasure to introduce
our keynote speaker, Sarah Demers,
the Horace D. Taft Associate
Professor of Physics.
Professor Demers is an award winning
distinguished member of the Yale faculty,
and an excellent example
of the intellectual
possibilities ahead of you.
After receiving her AB
from Harvard University,
Professor Demers attended
the University of Rochester,
Harvard is a good school.
And so is University of Rochester.
And where she was awarded
her MA and PhD in physics.
After teaching at Roberts Wesleyan College
and serving as a research associate
at Stanford's Linear Accelerator Center,
Professor Demers joined
the Yale faculty in 2009
as Assistant Professor of Physics.
And in the spring of 2020,
she'll be singing, teaching
a course, did I say sing?
She'll be teaching a course
titled The Physics of Music.
Professor Demers researches physics
beyond the standard model at
CERN's Large Hadron Collider,
and is currently studying
Higgs boson and Z boson decays.
She also works on the trigger
experiment for the study.
In addition, she leads
the Demers Group at Yale,
co-leads the ATLAS Upgrade Physics Group,
becomes the elected Chair
of the US Atlas Institute
Board in January,
and is a member of the Mu2e
collaboration at Fermilab.
Professor Demers is the
cofounder of the Yale Franke
and Whitney Humanities Center Group,
Interdisciplinary Arts
and Science Research
with Associate Professor
of Theater Studies
and Director of the Dance
Studies curriculum, Emily Coates.
She also collaborates
with Professor Coates
on a project that bridges
physics and dance,
and they co-teach a course
called The Physics of Dance,
and co-wrote a book called
"Physics and Dance."
That's really cool, isn't she?
So as you think about the journeys
you're about to start tomorrow,
you cannot have a better
guide than Professor Demers.
Please join me in welcoming her.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Dean Chun,
and welcome to each and every one of you.
I am really grateful for the chance
to pause with you this afternoon
before starting in with the academic year
that stretches out in front of us.
I'm only one of many people
at Yale who cares about you.
We're excited about what you
bring to this institution.
We're in anticipation of
what we'll learn from you.
And we have the highest expectations
for what you will gain while you're here
and what you'll take away.
But no pressure.
You're here on purpose, you
just have to do your best.
So, what's your plan?
How are you going to navigate
the resources that surround you?
I've been here for about a
decade, a decade and two months.
And I'm still coming to terms
with what we have access to.
Research tools, galleries, studios,
machine shops, libraries,
it's overwhelming.
Say about the experts
who populate this space.
In our time this afternoon,
I have two themes that I
want to explore with you,
and I'll end with a suggestion.
The two themes are balance
and, obviously, napkins.
The suggestion has to
do with your questions.
And before I get started,
I just wanna note
I'm speaking to you today as
a member of this community,
as a faculty member, as a physicist.
I'm not a dean, I'm not a medical doctor,
I'm not currently your professor,
and I'm one perspective of many,
so you should keep that in mind.
So, how are you going to choose
from our thousands of courses?
Balance is a reasonable goal.
How will you balance your coursework
with the hundreds of
extracurricular activities
I'm sure you have already signed up for?
How are you gonna balance
sustaining your connections
from home while building
your networks here?
How are you gonna balance
pursuing what you know you love
with discovering what you could love?
And this is related, but
it's a little different.
How are you gonna balance doubling down on
what you're good at with training yourself
in new ways and becoming
an expert in something new?
How are you gonna
balance your inward focus
on your education and your college time
with an outward focus on our community
in New Haven and beyond?
Will you be truly advanced, above average,
and actually get enough sleep?
Consider it, you're worth it.
As you do your calculations
and make your decisions,
balanced seems like a
reasonable guiding principle.
And it's come more and more into fashion.
Work life balance, that idea has resulted
in important societal
changes, positive changes.
I spent a lot of time
thinking about balance
in a lot of different contexts.
And do you know what?
I actually think that
it can miss the point.
And before I defend that statement,
let me introduce some physics.
You didn't think you were gonna get away
without some physics?
Okay, so what are the
conditions for balance?
How does a physical system stay balanced?
The center of mass has to
be over an area of support.
If your center of mass comes out
away from your area of
support, you start to fall.
So, what is an area of support?
Well, you take the
contact that you're making
with the ground, in my case,
right now it's my two feet.
And then it includes that area of contact
with the area that spans it,
meaning the rectangle
between my two feet, okay?
So the wider my stance, the
bigger my area of support.
As I go down to one foot,
which you can't see,
but I promise I'm doing, briefly,
my area of support is very constrained.
If I go up on my toes,
I have very little room
for my center of mass to
wiggle before I start to fall.
And let's stick to a concrete
physical system here for a while.
My challenge with balance as a goal.
You can be balanced
under a tremendous load,
and you also can be
balancing and exhausted.
That's why when people ask
me, as they frequently do,
about my work life
balance, I tell them, "No."
I hear that question and I
imagine walking on a tightrope
with my work in one outstretched arm
and my life in the other,
whatever that means.
And I imagine if I'm gonna
add a little more work,
I have to add a little more life.
And the next thing you know,
you find yourself at three
o'clock in the morning
making cookies for your kids' classrooms
because you agreed to serve
on a committee for Dean Chun,
it is the way of madness, that balance.
I love those committees, I do.
But my goal is not to balance,
as positive and important
as balance can be.
My goal is to thrive.
And that's what I hope
for you here at Yale.
So how do we thrive?
We have to know who we are
and who we wanna become.
We have to know who we love, who loves us.
We have to understand what
sustains us and what drains us.
I want to be centered, and
I think that's the point.
And if it means that I spend
some time balanced, then fantastic.
When I'm centered, I don't have to remain
in my basketball defensive
stance that I learned,
I actually can go up on
point when I have to.
And I can move my center of mass out
in front of my source of support.
You know what that is, when you
move your center of mass out
in front of your source of support?
It's called walking.
You fall and catch yourself, right?
That's what moving is,
it's falling and catching.
When you're centered, you can do that,
and I recommend that over balanced.
And I suggest thriving over reacting.
I have one last comment on that topic
before we move on to napkins,
which I know you're waiting for.
If you wanna be centered,
you actually have to
know what your center is.
You need time to reflect.
And the most common mistake
we can make in this context
is giving short shrift to
thinking and to sleeping.
And you know what that means.
It means that you have to turn
off your phone and reflect.
So now for napkins.
I grew up, kindergarten
through eighth grade
in a small town in
Vermont, Groton, Vermont,
a town of about 600.
My father is a United Methodist pastor.
He originally trained as a pianist,
and my mother studied art
history and education.
And I'm convinced that the
only job my mother can't do
is the one that she
explicitly trained for.
She lasted about a day in a
middle school teaching art
before she decided no.
But she's been a milk
tester for dairy farms,
she's worked in a nursing
home, done hospice care,
run a chamber of commerce,
been a telemarketer,
run a shelter for victims
of domestic violence,
run a homeless shelter, et cetera.
If there's a complicated job
that doesn't involve getting 25 students
to simultaneously paint, call my mother.
I didn't grow up in a wealthy
or a formal household.
And the goal that I was raised with
was not to do well in the
world, but to do good.
As I was entering high school, we moved
to the booming metropolis
of Morrisville, Vermont,
over 1000 people, and we
had our own movie theater.
One screen, but our own theater.
There were AP classes in my school,
advanced placement classes,
yeah, for college credit.
And the person who taught
my AP calculus class
was my AP English teacher.
And we started calculus
with the quote of the day.
And I'll never forget that
quote of the day discussion
stretching into half of the course period.
And getting to the AP test
and not recognizing those curly S things
that some of you may know as integrals,
and if you don't know
that, come talk to me,
I'd love to talk to you about calculus,
so that didn't go necessarily well.
I was an extremely ambitious kid,
so I really had run out of classes
by the end of my junior year.
And as has already been confessed,
I was not as enlightened as all of you,
at that point, I applied to Harvard.
Can get that out if you have to.
It was a year early from a small school
that nobody had heard of.
I knew that they were need blind,
so my family could afford it.
And I had multiple alumni interviews.
In an incredible twist of fate,
my final alumni interviewer,
her children had been my dad's students
when he was a music teacher
before going to seminary.
She was compassionate and connected.
And she knew that I wasn't
getting into Harvard
from a school that no one
had heard of a year early
with marginal accomplishments.
She asked me if I'd ever
considered private school,
and I told her it wasn't an option
because we couldn't afford it.
But she knew about
scholarship opportunities,
and she set me up with an interview
at Philips Academy in Andover,
and I ended up doing my senior year there.
There's one experience in particular
that has stuck with me from Andover.
I can't remember why,
but I didn't go home for Thanksgiving.
So I was invited to the head of school's
house for Thanksgiving.
And I remember the room, walking in,
and the dark wood paneling everywhere.
But mostly, I remember the place settings.
I don't know how you feel
about place settings.
I was trained on place
settings, it was one of my jobs.
Plate in the center, fork on the left,
knife and spoon on the right,
napkin folded under the fork.
That's how we did it
when I was growing up.
This place setting had multiple knives,
multiple spoons, multiple forks.
It had things to the left of the plate,
to the right of the plate,
and then the indignity of it,
stretching on top of the
plate, moving away from me.
Most alarming from my perspective
was the construction on top of my plate.
It was a 3D conglomeration
that I recognized
as my napkin exactly where
the food is supposed to go.
I knew I had to be on point.
There were rules.
Nobody was talking about them,
and I was gonna have to pay attention.
I looked up just to see
that every napkin was gone except my own.
All napkins missing.
And it was one of those
moments where you realize
something here is not like the other.
It probably only took me
a fraction of a second
to see those napkins on people's laps.
I remember thinking,
"I do not understand, what is the purpose,
"what is the utility of
the napkin on the lap?"
Since then, it's saved me
many times from spills.
But at the time, I thought that
was a little bit ridiculous,
but I was going with the flow,
my napkin went on my lap.
This idea that there are rules,
and it's obvious that there are rules,
but no one is talking about them
and you don't know what they are.
I call those things napkin moments.
And I've had many of them.
After Andover, I was accepted to Harvard.
I didn't have a lot of time
to figure out a summer job
between high school and
going back before college,
so I took on two positions.
I was a maid at a resort in Stowe,
and I was maintaining tennis courts,
which required spreading
a lot of chemicals.
And it's likely that exposure to chemicals
in one of those two contexts
landed me with an autoimmune disease.
So the week that I was
supposed to be at Harvard
for orientation, I was having surgery,
and I had to miss the year.
You're well placed to think about this.
At Harvard in those days,
and maybe it's true,
I don't know if it's true here.
If you miss orientation,
you miss the year,
they say, "Come back in a year."
I remember going to orientation
the next year and thinking,
"They have overestimated how
valuable this experience is."
(audience laughing)
I'm sure you don't feel
that way right now.
Anyway, it was ironic,
the kid who wants to go
to college a year early
ends up going a year late,
but it gave me the gift of arriving
to college fairly centered.
And my napkin moments
continued in college.
They weren't only social,
they were also academic.
I remember my first physics
classroom at Harvard,
walking in, and there
was a cluster of people,
it was a reunion, and they were
talking about the Physics Olympics.
And I remember thinking, "Isn't that cute?
"Physics Olympics, like the
Olympics except for physics."
And I realized, "Oh, that is a real thing.
"I'm probably in the wrong
classroom right now."
And it turns out that I was,
there was shopping period there as well,
I was able to adjust.
I took an astronomy class
with about a dozen students
and I was the only woman in the class.
Our professor spent a
lot of time communing
with the blackboard, which I understand.
But he did occasionally turn
around and interact with us.
We had a ritual once a week
when he would hand back our homework.
And he would read off our
names one at a time, "Daniel,"
and he would scan the room, and
Daniel would raise his hand,
"James," and, "Jonathan,"
and he would inevitably get to, "Sarah."
My classmates begged me,
"Please don't raise your
hand, see what he does."
Will he actually connect
the one female sounding name
with the one female
looking person in the room
who has consistently
raised her hand to Sarah?
But of course, I didn't wanna
make it any more uncomfortable
in those moments than it
already was scanning the room.
So I didn't really pause.
And it's never been clear to me
if he just was really a warrior
of trying to not see gender,
he was helping me out,
or if he really was that oblivious,
I think he might have been.
The problem sets in that class
were actually my true napkin moments.
I remember reading the problems,
and they went something like this.
You have designed and constructed
a 250 kilogram rocket and
launched it toward Mars.
How long will its journey take?
Hint, take into account
the rotation of the earth.
I'm sure that there was
more information provided,
but that's about the
level that I was getting.
And I remember thinking to myself,
"I'm not just missing something,
"I think I'm missing everything."
And I don't know if you've
had that experience.
It's interesting.
There were rules in lots
of different instances,
and I didn't know them.
One last example from a philosophy class
where there's a very special way
to write a philosophy
paper, I remember writing,
making argument X eight
times in three different ways
and getting the feedback,
you haven't made argument X.
In spite of really dedicated teachers
and a year at Andover, I was underprepared
and confused in physics
throughout much of college.
And there are three things
that I want to acknowledge
while we're together about napkin moments.
The first thing to acknowledge is
that they really can be exhausting.
If you're at a place that
feels like a different planet,
it's gonna take some energy.
Anyone who's lived in a foreign country
knows what this feels like,
and we have international
students with us here.
We have non-traditional students,
veterans who are returning to school,
we have transfer students,
we have a lot of first
generation students.
Many of us are gonna continue
to have napkin moments
over the course of this year.
The second thing to point out
is that they can be productive.
If you find yourself comfortable
to the point where you're
not being challenged,
make sure you seek out those opportunities
to be productively uncomfortable.
I'll give you an example.
I am productively uncomfortable
when I co-teach physics of
dance with Professor Coates,
and we're lined up on one
side of the dance studio.
And she tells us to make
our way to the other side,
giving us some kind of an
improvisational prompt.
That is terror, but
productive terror for me.
And I encourage you to seek out ways
to be challenged if you haven't been.
The last thing that I want to say
is to keep in mind that when
you feel the least equipped
and like you least belong,
those times might be
the very times when you
have the most to give.
In spite of my hiccups
with the philosophy papers,
which were substantial,
I considered myself a humanities person.
Physics challenged me and thrilled me
From the moment I learned
about coordinate systems,
which is kind of embarrassing
to admit, but it's true.
And it took me many, many
years to get to a point
where I was thinking like a physicist.
Now it's really second nature
to me, and my other talents
and inclinations have
come along for the ride,
and it makes me a better physicist.
The last thing I wanna talk about,
I know that it's warm,
you're all doing well.
There's more physics coming.
The last thing I wanna talk
about is your questions.
Because I have an organizational principle
to suggest for your time here.
It's not gonna help
you choose your courses
or your extracurricular activities,
but it might give you a
new way to pay attention
and make the most of the
situations you find yourself in.
It's not a new idea.
It really crystallized
for me when I was reading
The Chronicle of Higher Education.
Do you know about
productive procrastination?
It's a good one to figure out.
You shouldn't procrastinate.
But when you do procrastinate,
how much better to have
accomplished something
you're proud of in addition
to the guilt that you feel
and the problems that you've
dug yourself deeper in?
So for me, I read The
Chronicle of Higher Education
to procrastinate, and in 2013,
there was an article by James Lang
that referenced a book about
successful college students,
written by Ken Bain,
"What the Best College Students Do."
I don't often put much stock
in those kinds of books,
but Ken Bain wrote a very insightful book
about teaching and what it is
to become a better teacher,
so I was optimistic,
and there were a lot
of good ideas in there.
The one that stuck with me is
identify your questions,
and carry your questions
with you everywhere.
So, what are your questions?
What is it that you as an
individual wonder about?
What do you worry about?
It could be big questions,
questions like how do we create
and maintain justice in a society?
Or, how can I use my privilege
to open doors for others?
Or, how do we get the
plastics out of the ocean?
Identify your most urgent
questions and carry them with you.
If you are thinking about justice,
assume that your math
class, your painting course,
and your time playing intramural soccer
all have something to contribute.
It's a way for you to take responsibility
and some level of direction
for your education,
and let you, with your unique skills,
background, perspective, make connections
and discoveries that otherwise
wouldn't be possible.
Like all advice, this is
potentially dangerous.
What I do not mean by this
is for you to walk into your
classes, ignore the syllabi,
and bend the course to your own will.
You're at a research university,
so your faculty are
theorists and practitioners
who are immersed in our disciplines.
We bring our own goals and discipline
specific questions to the table,
and we're well informed.
Your own questions are a supplement.
They aren't an excuse to stop listening,
they're a motivation to listen well.
The assumption with that kind of listening
is that the information is relevant
and you could learn
something transformative.
And they actually enable you
to contribute in unexpected ways.
What I wanna do with our remaining time
is walk you through
just one of my questions
and share some of what I've learned
by this way of interacting with the world.
So, here's the question.
Why does the universe have a speed limit?
I'm fascinated by velocity.
How fast are we going right now?
We don't appear to be moving at all,
but we're falling around
the sun at between
15 to 20 miles per second.
It's very peaceful, if warm.
We aren't near the center of the galaxy,
which is actually for the
best, because we think
there's a massive black hole
at the center of the galaxy.
We're out in the spiral of the Milky Way,
and it takes our solar system
a few hundred million
miles to complete an orbit.
That means that we're moving
at about 150 miles per second.
Our galaxy moves throughout
the local group of galaxies,
and if we think even bigger,
our universe appears to be in a period
of accelerating expansion.
In spite of all of this relative motion,
we will not, it seems,
find a pair of objects
that are moving faster
than the speed of light
with respect to each other.
Our universe has a speed limit.
We're gonna dive in one more step,
because I'm a particle physicist
and you're Yale students, we can do this.
Thinking about fundamental particles,
we have a few examples without mass.
Photons are particles of light,
gluons, they're involved
in the strong force,
quantum chromodynamics.
And we've theorized gravitons,
mediators of gravity.
Those particles have no mass,
and by definition, only
move at the speed of light.
If you have a particle with
even a little bit of mass,
you can't get that particle
to the speed of light.
Which means that velocity is
intrinsically tied to mass.
And the mechanism of
mass discovered in 2012
is the Higgs field, something
that I'm studying right now,
which ties into one of
my fundamental questions.
Without the Higgs field,
elementary particles
would be zooming around
at the speed of light.
So my question about the
speed limit of the universe
is really linked to the question of mass.
In 2012, reasonably soon after
the discovery of the Higgs
by my collaboration and another,
I was with a few hundred
of my very good friends,
we were still celebrating the discovery.
And at the back of the auditorium,
I ran into a colleague of mine
who is a really talented
science communicator.
I asked him, "So, how's it
going, talking about the Higgs?"
And he said, "It's hard, it's
really difficult to explain.
"In a public setting, you don't pull out
"quantum mechanics and field theory."
And I agreed, it was a challenge for us.
So I looked for help.
I collaborate, as you've heard,
with Professor Emily Coates.
There was a grant that was being offered
by the New Haven Council
for the Arts to support
artist scientist teams,
it was called Reintegrate,
and it was trying to pull pairs
of artists and scientists together.
And Emily and I were
looking for something to do
associated with it, and I asked her,
"Can we tackle the Higgs boson for this?"
In the process of our work together,
Emily went to one of my
public lectures on the Higgs.
And she asked me after,
"Do you have any idea what you're doing
"when you're talking up there?
"You're making all kinds of motions,
"you're basically dancing the
Higgs as you're up there."
And I said, "No, I had no idea,
"and it's problematic to hear that
"because I'm gonna be self conscious
"for the rest of my life now
talking about the Higgs boson."
And she asked me, "Do you know
if your colleagues do this?"
And I said, "I have no idea."
So we set off to CERN to
interview some of my colleagues.
And we asked them, "Describe the Higgs,"
and we collected their analogies.
And we watched how their
interactions of their bodies
actually mapped to the
words they were using.
In this process, I thought very deeply
about the ways that I was imagining
the Higgs mechanism to work.
As I talked about it,
as I thought about it.
And noticed the pieces that weren't safe,
places where I'd lifted
in macroscopic ideas
to describe a microscopic phenomenon.
And it forced me to go back and look
more deeply, more carefully at the theory.
It's the people who
understand the concepts
that are really the best place to come up
with a safe analogy, right?
The moral of this story for me is that
we shouldn't narrow ourselves prematurely
when it comes to our questions.
If you care about getting
plastics out of the ocean,
don't take only courses on
plastics and courses on oceans.
I learned more about mass
through working with a choreographer
than I ever could have imagined I would.
And I know this may
seem like a selfish way
to approach the liberal arts.
It's basically looking
around with your questions
and thinking, "All of these things
"can teach me about my stuff."
But I really think it's
the best compliment
you can pay another discipline, to say,
"I believe that you're
relevant to what I care about,
"and there are insights
that can be offered
"that are only limited by my ignorance,
"and I can't even imagine
the connections yet."
And your stuff and your questions
will change in your time here.
I know that you will discover questions
if you're paying attention.
Conversations with each other,
inside and outside of the classroom.
And I hope and assume that
some of your questions
are gonna evolve through
your interactions,
again, with each other inside
and outside of the classroom.
I'm gonna free us all soon,
because I know we need time
to sleep and time to think.
Just a few more words.
Balance, I think it's a useful framework,
but it misses something
that I think is critical.
I really want you all to thrive here,
and that can occasionally require focus.
Good luck with your napkin moments,
you're actually not alone.
Remember, define your questions
and carry them with you everywhere.
At this point, we're not here
for your accomplishments,
we're here for your potential.
And one last analogy.
This institution is not a
fancy Thanksgiving dinner,
and the course catalog is not a menu.
You aren't surrounded by
assembled dishes here,
you're surrounded by ingredients.
Because you don't consume an education,
you have to construct it.
So, turn off your phone, get
some sleep, do your best,
find the help when you need it.
And when you can, embrace
the challenges you face
that train your brain in productive ways
to access the world in different ways.
Thank you very much for your time
and attention this afternoon,
and I really look forward
to seeing you around campus.
(audience applauding)
- So, Professor Demers,
thank you for that
amazing, inspiring words.
And I hope you all will
take her advice to,
as you get to know each other
over the next four years,
share your napkin moments with each other,
share your questions and
help each other find balance.
You're gonna have a big reception
in your residential colleges
followed by a formal dinner,
a Thanksgiving-like
dinner in the dining hall.
It's really a memorable
event and a great way
to spend the evening before
your first day of classes here.
So, I hope you look forward to that,
and you all look really wonderful
and handsome and lovely.
But before we leave today, as promised,
you're gonna learn one of our
really most beautiful traditions.
And so we have the world
renowned Yale Glee Club
with us here together with our
most distinguished director,
Jeff Douma, who's going to teach
you "Bright College Years,"
so please give a warm welcome.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Dean Chun.
Hi, everyone, good afternoon.
As Dean Chun explained,
we conclude the address
by inviting all of you to join in
a time honored Yale College tradition,
the singing of our alma
mater, "Bright College Years."
I have a few members of the Yale Glee Club
here to help me out.
They're gonna sing through
verse one once for you
so you can hear what it sounds like.
And after that, I will
invite all of you to stand
and to sing verses one and two together
as they are printed on
the back of the program.
It's our tradition at the
end of the second verse
to wave our handkerchiefs in the air,
so be ready for that and follow our lead.
Sing out loud, sing out
strong, and welcome to Yale.
("Bright College Years")
♪ Bright college years,
with pleasure rife ♪
♪ The shortest, gladdest years of life ♪
♪ How swiftly are ye gliding by ♪
♪ Oh, why doth time so quickly fly? ♪
♪ The seasons come, the seasons go ♪
♪ The earth is green or white with snow ♪
♪ But time and change ♪
♪ Shall naught avail ♪
♪ To break the friendships ♪
♪ Formed at Yale ♪
♪ Bright college years,
with pleasure rife ♪
♪ The shortest, gladdest years of life ♪
♪ How swiftly are ye gliding by ♪
♪ Oh, why doth time so quickly fly? ♪
♪ The seasons come, the seasons go ♪
♪ The earth is green or white with snow ♪
♪ But time and change ♪
♪ Shall naught avail ♪
♪ To break the friendships ♪
♪ Formed at Yale ♪
♪ In after years, should troubles rise ♪
♪ To cloud the blue of sunny skies ♪
♪ How bright will seem
through memory's haze ♪
♪ Those happy, golden, bygone days! ♪
♪ Oh, let us strive that ever we ♪
♪ May let these words our watch cry be ♪
♪ Wher-e’er upon ♪
♪ Life's sea we sail ♪
♪ For God, for country ♪
♪ And for Yale! ♪
(audience applauding and cheering)
(gentle music)